conservative party conference has just
kicked off but we've already been here
for a couple of days watching them set
up so what's it like to be a journalist
here at a party conference and more
importantly what do the members expect
from boris johnson let's find out
[Music]
streaming into the conference center the
first of the members heading for the
stands where charities and businesses
set up shop
it's also where you'll find the media
broadcasters like the bbc and gb news
and radio stations too welcome back to
tng times radius
let's go and find out where sky news
is a big argument here right at the
heart of the action
and there's lots of fringe events too
like this one going on right now future
pandemics
and they
um they've been doing a training session
and hey joe what have you got burritos
they are delicious they're hot they're
tasty we've always got our eye on what's
happening in the main auditorium and
this is where the cabinet are going to
be delivering their speeches throughout
the rest of the week
i want to offer our deepest and most
heartfelt thanks
[Applause]
welcome to the press room so this is
where all of the journalists work
throughout the whole conference we're
gonna have a chat hello
with mikey from the mirror you guys will
be working on your stories for later
tonight yeah um all day
stories
coming from fringe events let me show
you something in fact just a moment ago
this is what they were giving out with
the liz trust fringe
so the journalists at the conference
they're all watching out for what boris
johnson says in his main speech because
this is a really big moment for the
prime minister what exactly do you think
roy johnson needs to do at this
conference to kind of prove to his
membership that he's got a handle on
things
well um this is the first time he's
addressed the party faithful since the
pandemic so he'll be wanting to pivot
away from some of the things he's been
focused on for the past 18 months and
trying to talk a bit more about his
delivery agenda for the rest of his
premiership gavin can i grab you just
for two seconds before you do your book
lunch thank you gavin barwell was
theresa may's chief of staff when her
conference speech went terribly wrong in
2017.
you can't get something for nothing
in all its diversity compassion and
strength
that were shared around the globe
pharmacists will spend a lot of time
that you won't see on camera going
around all the receptions and meeting
the donors and senior activists and a
lot of time on speech but obviously how
how the public and how you probably
judge is what happens in that speech on
wednesday so can boris johnson do it he
has to navigate tricky domestic issues
and show he's got a long-term plan for
levelling up too
expectations high
it's a real opportunity to set out what
we're going to do post-favorites uh
leveling up agenda to kind of put a bit
more flesh onto the bones of it
yeah i know that i know that i'm very
much
back on set we're here right into the
evening as speeches finish in the main
hall and the parties start to kick off
then tomorrow we get up and do it all
over again
and the one thing that the party will
really want to hear from boris johnson
at this particular conference is what
leveling up really means how that
translates into policy that will deliver
for voters on the doorstep